by following Friday's special council
indictment at 13 Russians the liberal
mainstream destroy Trump media went out
of their way to attack the president as
they usually do and cast an ominous
shadow over the future of the Trump
administration doom gloom hysteria daily
and they've been wrong the whole time
it's now obvious that the Russians were
trying to interfere in our election well
it appears the stress might be getting
to them this is getting closer and
closer and closer to the Trump inner
circle are the White House staff getting
more and more worried about that or is
this just Donald Trump freaking out
about it alone
it may just be Donald Trump freaking out
about it alone but his staff has to be
freaking out about his freakout right
the big stuff is probably yet to come
and indeed it does seem as though Muller
is just beginning to lay the groundwork
but stay tuned for more what concerns me
is that Donald Trump seems to be more
upset about the Mueller vest and the
molar investigation and what came out
from that the Saturday morning then
these kids who were shot
I think Trump's got some problems I
don't think Muller would have taken the
case if he didn't see a serious problem
here some of the dumbest people work in
this profession joining us now Michelle
Malkin investigates ER t v-- michelle
malkin okay Hillary Rodham Clinton paid
for Russian and Russian government lies
to lie to the American people in the
lead-up to the election then it wasn't
verified it was used to get a FISA
warrant because they never told the
judge the truth and we have Hillary
Clinton and Eric called the Barack Obama
administration we have Putin operatives
involved in money laundering extortion
kickbacks and bribery and they got 20%
of America's uranium nobody in the media
is telling their viewers about these
important things why because it doesn't
fit their narratives and they are going
to go kicking and screaming like
toddlers in a tantrum as long as they
can to deny the truths that you are
reporting nightly Sean and the reaction
and the responses that you showed
in the wake of this underwhelming
indictment on Friday show that so much
of the opposition media is part of their
own 4-h club you mentioned hysteria it's
also hyperbole hyperventilate
ventilation and also hypocrisy because
when there are plain and obvious neon
flashing signs and evidence of foreign
meddling and corruption not just the
Iranian one deal but so many others over
the stretch of both Republican and
Democrat administrations this 4-h club
of the opposition media has been nowhere
to be found
and you have to have a little bit of
historical perspective here to shun I
mean these are the same people that look
the other way at Walter Duran tea and
the clear and convincing and
overwhelming infiltration of communist
agents during the Roosevelt
administration these are people who have
looked the other way at saudi and
chinese and Mexican meddling in our
elections so the idea that they care now
and our are touting this indictment as
somehow on the order of 9/11 or Pearl
Harbor as some of these more hysterical
journalists have done please their
hypocrisy is showing and it's the true
colors of this media they don't care
about foreign meddling in this election
they care about bringing down President
Trump you know I'll give you it's always
been about that you know what I've never
understood about Muller one guy in the
world Julian Assange he knows where he
got his information from doesn't he in
terms of the DNC now if they wanted to
find out the leak and where that they
would ask him at least ask at least try
to talk to the guy that's never happened
so what what I see about Muller is here
you have all of this other evidence
Muller was the FBI director when we had
an informant inside of the actual
operation of Vladimir Putin in this
country and the fact that the media is
acting all surprised and feigning such
moral outrage
it is just one huge massive lie it's not
true Michelle because he got 20% of our
uranium how stupid are we that he got
20% of our uranium we handed it to him
and we knew these crimes were committed
on our soil and they did nothing yes
that's right
you know 2009 I came out with a book
called culture of corruption and I
pointed to all of the ways in which
Chicago and the Potomac and the Obama
administration were endangering our
national security our public safety
every last pillar of civil order in our
country and I feel somewhat vindicated
but I'm not going to cheer about it that
the deep state has posed the greatest
amount of threat to the fabric of our
nation and we certainly didn't need 13
Russian trolls - so that division and
chaos because so much of it of course
has been advanced not just by the Obama
operatives that remain in the deep State
for goodness sake there are Clinton and
Carter era barnacles is still in that
deep state and in Foggy Bottom and and
embedded in all of our intelligence and
law enforcement agencies but of course
the biggest sewers of division within
American soil are those operatives in
the so-called mainstream media so
corrupt and it's all boomeranging back I
said 2018 will be the year the boomerang
as it relates to these issues Michelle
as always thank you when we come